>> MIKE: BATTLES, TARGETING A
PIZZA CRIME FOR PAINTING AN
AMERICAN FLAG MURAL.
LAURA SPOKE EARLIER WITH THE
BISTRO OWNER, WHO ORGANIZED A
PARADE TO SUPPORT THE FLAG.
LET'S WATCH.
>> LAURA: BEFORE YOU HAD THIS
MURAL PAINTED, I GUESS IT WAS AN
OLD WALL AND YOU WANTED TO
SPRUCE IT UP, YOU HAD SOME
PROBLEMS, I UNDERSTAND, WITH
PROTESTORS, AND FOR PEOPLE WHO
DON'T KNOW WHERE THIS IS, THIS
IS IN NEW PALTZ, NEW YORK, 80
MILES NORTH OF NEW YORK CITY,
AND IT'S 14,000, 12,000 PEOPLE.
WHAT WAS THEIR BEEF ABOUT THE
FLAG?
>> WELL, THEY DIDN'T WANT A
FLAG.
THEY THOUGHT IT MEANT A
POLITICAL POSITION, AND THEY
WERE OPPOSED.
>> LAURA: WHAT POLITICAL PASSION
IS A FLAG OTHER THAN THIS IS THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA?
DID YOU ENGAGE IN ANY
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM?
>> NO, I DIDN'T.
I REALLY DIDN'T INTERACT WITH
THEM AT ALL.
I JUST OBSERVED.
>> LAURA: WERE THEY STANDING
OUTSIDE?
WERE THEY COMING IN AND
EXPRESSING THEMSELVES VERBALLY
TO YOU SAYING, I'M NOT GOING TO
EVER ORDER ONE OF YOUR PIZZAS OR
GRINDERS, OR WHAT?
>> I DID HAVE A FEW PEOPLE COME
IN AND SAY THEY COULDN'T SUPPORT
MY STORE ANY LONGER BECAUSE THEY
FELT I TOOK A POLITICAL
POSITION, SO THEY COULDN'T SPEND
THEIR MONEY.
>> LAURA: WAIT A SECOND.
OKAY.
ARE THESE COLLEGE KID BECAUSE I
KNOW YOU'VE GOT A COLLEGE -- A
STATE UNIVERSITY, IN NEW PALTZ
IN TOWN.
>> YES.
>> LAURA: WERE THEY COLLEGE
KIDS?
>> NO, IN PARTICULAR, THAT WAS
NOT A COLLEGE KID THAT CAME IN
AND TOLD ME THAT.
>> LAURA: THAT'S A RELIEF THAT
HAPPENED, AND THEN FAST FORWARD
TO THE PAINT SPLATTERED ALL OVER
THE MURAL.
PEOPLE ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE
WONDERING, WHY ARE WE FOCUSED ON
THIS SMALL TOWN IN NEW YORK AND
THIS ONE MURAL IN THIS ONE
DEFACING OF A MURAL.
WE'RE FOCUSING ON IT BECAUSE
IT'S OUR FLAG.
AND IT REPRESENTS A LOT.
JOEY, YOU'RE A VETERAN.
YOU SAW THAT THIS HAD HAPPENED
THE IN YOUR HOMETOWN.
YOU DECIDED TO DO WHAT AND WHY?
>> WHEN I SAW THE PUSH BACK SHE
WAS GETTING FOR PUTTING AN
AMERICAN FLAG MURAL UP I
PERSONALLY HAD A PROBLEM WITH
THAT SO I HAD THE IDEA, WHY
DON'T WOVE AN EVENT WHERE WE ALL
JUST COME TOGETHER IN SUPPORT OF
THE FLAG AND IN SUPPORT OF THE
MURAL AND SHOW OUR SUPPORT.
AND IT WASN'T SURE HOW IT WAS
GOING TO GO, WHAT KIND OF
TURNOUT WE WOULD GET.
WE $UP HAVING LIKE 400 OR 500
PEOPLE TO COME OUT.
IT WAS AMAZING.
WE ALL HAD OUR FLAGS.
WE SHOWED OUR SUPPORT.
IT WAS A GREAT, POSITIVE,
PEACEFUL DAY.
>> LAURA: JOEY, DID YOU HAVE A
CHANCE TO SPEAK TO ANY OF THESE
BRAVE PROTESTORS WHO WERE
AGAINST THIS MURAL?
DID YOU EVER ENGAGE IN ANY
MEANINGFUL DIALOGUE WITH ANY OF
THEM?
>> I TRIED.
THERE WAS NOT MUCH MEANINGFUL
DIALOGUE TO BE HAD WITH MOST OF
THEM.
THE DAY OF THE EVENT, WE HAD
SOME OF THEM SHOW UP.
I TRIED TO TALK TO THEM, YOU
KNOW, TRIED EXPLAIN, HEY, YOU
GUYS HAVE THE RIGHT TO BE OUT
HERE, SO DO WE, LET'S KEEP IT
PEACEFUL.
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO HEAR ANY OF
THAT I WAS LABELED MANY
DIFFERENT NAMES BY PEOPLE, YOU
KNOW, FROM THESE PROTESTORS.
SOME PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY FOR
PUTTING THIS TOGETHER BUT IT WAS
JUST ABOUT SUPPORTING OUR FLAG,
MILITARY AND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
>> LAURA: JOEY, DOES IT SEEM
LIKE THESE PROTESTORS, JUST FROM
THE WAY THEY APPEARED, IT'S AN
AGGRESSIVE -- I DON'T KNOW IF
IT'S A PROTEST, IT AN AGGRESSIVE
INTIMIDATION CAMPAIGN.
THEY ARE TRYING TO INTIMIDATE
MARIA TO PUT SOMETHING ELSE UP
THERE, TO FRIGHTEN HER.
THAT'S WHY THEY HAVE LIKE, YOU
KNOW, BLACK FLAGS, IT LOOKS MORE
LIKE ISIS THAN ANY TYPE OF
PEACEFUL PROTESTS THAT I WAS
USED TO SEEING GROWING UP.
THEIR GOAL IS TO DO WHAT,
REALLY?
TO HAVE MORE DIALOGUE OR TO SHUT
IT DOWN?
>> TO SHUT IT DOWN.
THEY DISAGREE WITH IT SO THEY
WOULD RATHER IT JUST GO AWAY AND
NOT BE THERE, AND THEY DIDN'T
WANT US TO BE OUT THERE THAT
DAY, LIKE I SAID, WE HAVE HAD
400 OR 500 OF US, LIKE 20 OF
THEM.
>> LAURA: THAT'S GREAT.
>> WE JUST DID OUR THING.
OUR CHANTS FOR USA, THEIR
CHANTS, YOU CAN'T SAY ON TV.
>> LAURA: LOVELY.
UNITY AND DIVERSITY DAY, BY THE
WAY, IS SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN
CELEBRATED IN NEW PALTZ, NEW
YORK, UNITY AND DIVERSITY DAY.
HOW ABOUT A LITTLE UNITY BEHIND
OUR NATION AND THE IDEA OF
LIBERTY AND FREEDOM.
>> EXACTLY.
>> LAURA: GUYS, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR JOINING US TONIGHT.
WE REALLY, REALLY APPRECIATE IT,